GameSpot's next big game week marches on
as we continue to catalogue the classes
of the multiplayer Monster Hunter
evolved mr. Hyde
Maggy playing [ __ ] what yeah yeah we
play you come pass the toy you come oh
so you want to know what kind of duties
the trapper takes on that's not a
question that inspires a lot of
confidence hunter because it's right
there in the name you trap the monster
getting that behemoth in a room with you
and your fellow hunters is crucial to
mounting its head on your wall but first
you have to find it other trappers have
their methods but you Maggie
you have Daisy oh look at that cuddly
little boost
look at that a doe real alien dog who's
a good girl you are Daisy yes you are
don't run away
actually Daisy doesn't so much run away
from you as run towards the monster she
doesn't stray too far from Maggie so in
order to maximize her squid sniffing
ability you need to stay on her trail
once she gets close she'll slow down and
do her best pointer dog impression in
the direction of the monster so give her
the attention she deserves and she'll
reward you
I mean not with the cuddles and lids
that you so desperately want
unfortunately but Daisy does have a
helpful surprise for you or any of your
allies that get incapacitated around her
neck is a st. Bernard e'en revival
device that can get you back into the
fight or quit Haney huh and here you
thought Maggie just kept daisy around
for her looks once Daisy has led you to
your promised prey it's time to dome
that demon the mobile arena is this big
blue barrier that traps anyone and any
Beast within it cornering the monster is
absolutely key to bringing the full
killing power of your hunter crew to
bear so timely dome deployment is one of
the trappers primary responsibilities if
you miss the monster or if the tide
turns tragically against you you can
always bring down the dome manually and
continue your pursue or flee in terror
the dome will also go down if Maggie
gets incapacitated so be wary of getting
targeted by claustrophobic monsters who
don't like to be fenced in so the
monsters tract and domed what's a
trapper to do now well you've got these
nifty little harpoon mines see and if
the monster happens to get near one or
three of them whack the mines
automatically fire and pin the monster
in place it has a little wiggle room but
until it breaks those lines it's
basically spitted and ready to roast
place your mines in groups to compound
the tethering effect or on high ledges
to try to snag a Kraken in flight and
that's pretty much it for Maggie don't
think I'm forgetting anything here you
track the monster you trap the monster
you snare the monster and a hoe yeah
she's got this submachine gun too sure
yeah shoot the monster why not every
little bit helps right aim that high
fire rate towards one of the medic
induced weak points on the monster and
you could even make a significant dent
and maybe then Daisy will be impressed
enough to give you the snuggles you so
richly deserve probably not
schooldays Aruba which I assume is her
name in your native language but I do
not recognize it
it's Shona I figured you knew every
language the trick is knowing which
dictionaries to load a Bantu language I
guess